so in other news uh japan is back on
lockdown
no way we you know what we had a
pleasant
two weeks
what blows my mind is that they they
cancel spectators like
now for the olympics it's starting this
month right yeah like in a couple weeks
yeah what the [ __ ] actually by the time
this is up it's
probably probably started yeah it's
insane to me that they cancelled it
this like the spectators this late when
you know but the athletes are still live
yeah i mean that's that's i mean i get
that but like as if they didn't know how
bad the situation was it's like whoa
[ __ ]
get better suddenly what the [ __ ] you
know it's just to me it's insane that
you know it's also just irresponsible as
well because it's probably people who
booked hotels you know
because even in japan right you can come
from hokkaido where wherever the [ __ ]
you are you can come and watch
poor people probably book time off work
maybe probably booked some hotels yeah
they use their limited like
it's like the cyberpunk release but just
like on a scale of 10 times that you
know
you know somebody if somebody booked
time off work in japan
they ain't playing around that doesn't
happen like the japanese government just
puts out a tweet which is just like the
[ __ ] the yellow
i mean it's just yeah unfortunately
you're not we're gonna have to wait even
longer for the new figure episode
because uh we
yeah we're still under a new lockdown
and it just feels like
this entire year has just been a
lockdown but not really for us
it feels like now that the rest of the
world is kind of getting back to normal
it's really weird seeing timelines where
people are having parties and going out
without masks and stuff and i'm just
here like
yeah this is just this is just life this
is life yeah this is just life now for
us right
it's it's weird because it's like i
don't i know we've talked about this a
lot before but it's because it's such an
ongoing thing and it changes throughout
the time it's like
all right restaurants open all right
okay cool but now they're close to eight
all right okay but
now they consider alcohol okay but now
they can't it's like what what's going
on
what the [ __ ] is going on it's just i'm
so confused the limit is three no the
limit is six
the limit is four yeah yeah and then
it's like all right and then
google maps is completely unreliable now
because now not all the
opening and closing times are [ __ ]
live yeah because it's totally dependent
on the place and whether they're doing
it and
most of the time they're not the ones
updating their google page so you don't
even know if shit's open or not the only
thing that has
stayed consistent throughout this entire
thing
is corn minis that's literally the only
thing that stayed consistent pretty much
i mean you want to go to a new place now
you check out on google maps oh they're
open you turn up at the door
and they're not open and then you try to
find another place and it's just kind of
like playing a roulette wheel
of just seeing what you can do because
it's it's locked down has been really
weird because we say lock down but it's
just like
you can you can still go out and work
you just can't really do anything else
about that
i mean the trains are still [ __ ]
packed as [ __ ] oh yeah if you get an
eight o'clock train still
you know you're [ __ ] yeah it's you
know you do
you still get squeezed in like there
will be people pushing you in
still uh during all of this and that's
why a lot of the experts say it's
so worrying uh in tokyo because the
density is insane
yeah you can't you can't just social
distance anywhere in this [ __ ] town
um and yeah did you see that thing with
the tokyo
hotel or something where it was like the
foreigners have to get a different
elevator
from the japanese yeah i saw that i saw
that
classic japanese xenophobia i heard that
it was a misunderstanding i don't know
if this is true that's what they all
so i heard this was a misunderstanding
of especially for people who came from a
foreign country
uh right even though realistically right
now
you're probably safer if you've come
from a foreign country
yeah i think that was a lot of the even
though like some people were trying to
defend it being like no no they meant
people who just came in from like
america or whatever you know
and but a lot of people arguing so like
yeah well japan has not handled this
very well i don't think they're in the
place to be able to
you know i don't even think what is this
like less than 10 of the populations
got the vaccine right it's something
it's probably higher now but it just
comes out yeah but i mean still it's
like it's nowhere near where it should
be considering the olympics
to me it just seems like why not just
socially distance in general
in the elevator why not just let two
people go in at a time on the opposite
end why
have to make it like the distinction it
just yeah i don't know it's uh
i mean they could be that's just japan
is just a little
you know the thing that sucks about
japan is that they're just a little too
quick on the decision to make it harsh
on foreigners
they're a little too comfortable with
making those rules they're always
like a little too like it's like it's
something it's like is something wrong
it's the foreigners they're just a
little it's just it's just the speed at
which they'll be like
oh maybe we should just maybe just
discriminate a little bit
like you know i'm feeling a little
discriminated for it today
it's like the image of that guy falls
off the bicycle and she's like ah it's
the foreigners
you know i at the one time you know they
people do try and justify it and all
that but
it's just the ease at which sometimes
japan does it
which bothers me the most like we had
that thing from uh the i think did you
talk about the podcast the ibaraki
prefecture
uh i don't think we haven't talked about
that yeah
prefecture uh gave a warning out for
people not to interact with foreigners
that's right yeah that was one of their
um i think again people defended some
people defended it being like well they
have they only
have people from a foreign country but
there's no way for japanese people to be
able to distinguish between
a person who came from a foreign country
recently yeah
it was very obvious what they were
trying to say uh which was just stay
away from foreigners
yeah you know which uh i mean it's it's
it's like the massive yikes if if this
happened in literally
any other country they'd just be called
out for it right yeah
by by everyone you know i mean luckily
though in a sense like at least what
i've seen on social media
they have been called out yeah that's
why they're so quick to retract and
being like oh no it was a
misunderstanding
it was it was retracted very fast and i
mean you can imagine why
yeah yeah it's supposed to be very it's
an inverted the hotel is
like quite quite a uh what's it notable
hotel it's a big
franchise it's a big big it's generally
an expensive chain yeah
is it an expensive chain yeah the tokyo
hotel is a very lightweight
oh i didn't i thought it was just like
this really it's a premium hotel
and it you know normally for rich
tourists
it's like if the hilton was like no
asians yeah i think it's that level
it's you know so uh it's just uh
sad very sad yeah yeah
i forgot what i was gonna say something
i had a really good point but i [ __ ]
forgot
i'm dumb must have been a good point it
was such a riveting point but
oh well lost the time yeah oh well i
mean i mean it's just like it's
you know obviously we're grateful to be
here but it's just it's weird that
we it's it's not exactly that we feel
discriminated against
obviously it's just sometimes there's
just like a lot of little things that we
see
and we feel and obviously hearing news
like this it kind of like adds to that
little by little yeah i mean when i
speak to someone my age
i've never ever felt that in japan at
all i just feel that the government
and like almost in every country it's
just older people kind of out of touch
yeah really yeah i feel like that's but
i feel it's especially prevalent in
japan because again the older population
is gosh yeah yeah the majority right
yeah the
yeah the difference is that that's
totally fine because that's what they
voters want
exactly literally all the voters
olympic committee like just saying that
women women shouldn't talk
and just stay in the kitchen or
something like that there was something
it was something along the lines of
women shouldn't be allowed to talk at
meetings because
they talk to you yeah yeah at the
olympic olympic meetings
like that's what dudes in the 50s used
to say to their wives
but that was the ex-prime minister of
japan was it it was the
he was the prime minister of japan as
far as i'm aware can you google it to
confirm that but as far as i know it's
the ex prime minister of japan which
is just very telling um
i'm not saying you know the uk is much
better we're [ __ ] awful
yeah yeah uh but again they're very
quick to get called out by it but then
people calling out
the japanese government for a lot of
this stuff you know a lot of the time is
the younger people who are doing it like
yeah elderly the social media generation
yeah it was the ex prime minister of
japan
but he's also he's also like what 91
years old or something
and he's the [ __ ] like i'm not being
funny but no one 91 years old should be
making countrywide
i just i think at that point you were
just so far out of touch with the
country yeah absolutely you you can't
like
yeah i mean i mean it's just like at
that point you don't
really i mean you're 91 right why would
you care to change
for society because you know at that
point you already know who you
are you're not going to put in the
effort to change exactly um
and it's just yeah at that point you
probably shouldn't be running a
a country you know i mean like what job
like 70 something but then like bernie
makes me always think like damn okay
maybe old people maybe they know what's
up
oh yeah i think they forgot
i guess that says [ __ ]
i thought you're too political this is
probably the most political we've ever
gotten on the show
what's naming politicians
he said the name
yeah i don't know it's one of those
things where it's like i don't know it's
just
yeah they're a little too comfortable
with uh dishing that [ __ ] out